Mike chebet is on a mission to build the
next trillion dollar tech company and
this isn't just some marketing hype
every single person at his company
really believes it like literally every
single person from uh an EA all the way
up to the CEO if you ask how much is the
company going be worth to say trillion
dollar TR du trillion dollar company
which sounds insane until you're like oh
wait a second these people actually
believe this like we don't shy away from
saying that we were going to be bigger
than Microsoft or Amazon like everyone
in this room will not stop until that's
that's reality but instead of going
after something flashy like humanoid
robots mik is making his trillion dollar
bet against Automation and his company
will actually create more jobs for
American workers our mission is to
empower both businesses and workers to
resar full productivity and potential
this company is called tra and even
though startups are dying left and right
throughout Silicon Valley right now
Mike's company is growing insanely fast
and has already raised over $43 million
in funding in Just 2 years but how did
he build this so quickly and could it
really be the next trillion dollar
company well I sat down with Mike and
his team and learned that there are
three key strategies that could make
tra's trillion dollar bet a
[Music]
winner I'm Mike chevit and I'm the CEO
of tra to understand tra you first need
to understand Mike's early days in Tech
he grew up just outside Washington DC
went to college at the University of
Virginia to study economics and quickly
found himself on a traditional Finance
track Goldman Sachs Investment Banking
was the most prestigious job on Wall
Street for new grads but they weren't
hiring at his college so he had to
hustle and cold email his way into an
internship I just wrote a bunch of
essays and things like that on to to
submit to all these investment Banks and
then I ended up getting the Goldman soch
internship the plan worked but after a
few years working in finance he realized
he wanted to get his hands dirty in a
real business instead of just shuffling
spreadsheets for the rest of his life it
wasn't very intellectually stimulating
because hedge funds are not that
complicated from an operational
standpoint so he joined a company you've
probably never heard of McMaster Car
which if you look them up online it
looks boring it's like a bunch of screws
it's a bunch of bolts and hammers that
you buy so they reach out hey we have a
management rotation program we'd love to
get to know you even though they don't
have a consumer brand their parts power
a huge portion of the American economy
basx was a big customer of ours in La so
when SpaceX would have to build a
massive rocket they would be like let's
order a bunch of product from McMaster
Car the engineering supplier it was at
McMaster Car where Mike first came into
contact with the light Industrial
Staffing industry he would go on to try
and disrupt years later I know it sounds
boring but this experience would lay the
foundation of tra so part of my job with
with trying to manage that was of course
you want to manage your your team in the
warehouse but you also start relying on
Staffing so this that's how I discovered
the Staffing industry anytime the
company needed to ship out parts to a
customer Mike would have to call a bunch
of temporary staffing firms to try and
get them to send out workers to help
pack boxes and fulfill orders it was a
timeconsuming laborious process that
that was full of inefficiencies so then
that's when I felt the pain point so
that less than half the people show up
because the Staffing industry is an
archaic industry that is spoiled by the
business critical need that you're
solving because I don't have another an
option Mike learned a lot at McMaster
car but he still wanted to move faster
so he joined Uber and quickly earned a
reputation for his insane work ethic and
ability to get things done his managers
noticed and Mike was quickly tasked with
the job of launching Uber eats into new
markets I got the job at Uber Uber was
just about to launch Uber Eats so Uber
Eats had not existed it was a small
incubation in Los Angeles and Toronto
his story of how Uber launches new
markets is fascinating and it really
illustrates how young people can move
mountains when they have the autonomy to
execute quickly so basically I was
responsible for launching Rio de Janeiro
in Brazil so essentially what an Uber
launch looks like as you fly into the
market we have some idea what worked in
previous markets so so you have to build
out a sales team from scratch so you
drop into a market you hire a bunch of
people that are interested in sales you
build a lead list and then you have a
bunch of sales reps Clos a bunch of
restaurants then you start building out
your driver Supply so your Courier
Supply so now you have your drivers and
your couriers now you have to do like a
huge marketing stun for your eaters so
for Brazil we did free beer on Uber eat
and we literally went from being like
out of the top 100 on the App Store
because we were president in Sal Paulo
to number one in the app store and we
broke everything but like I got the
opportunity to scale that to 16
different countries so I got to see time
and time again like what works and what
goes in when building a Marketplace
product at a three-sided Marketplace
Uber Eats is harder than than like a
two-sided Marketplace so with McMaster
Car Mike had seen the timeconsuming
inefficiencies with temp Staffing and at
Uber Mike had learned how to solve the
chicken and egg problem involved in
launching a new Marketplace it was only
logical that he would put these two
skills together and start a company but
it was also the the perfect time for
this since America's supply chain was
about to go through massive upheaval the
pandemic has turned economies upside
down the National Labor shortage plays a
role in the supply chain challenges in
the time of Co 19 that's helping to
drive this whole Workforce shortage
across all Industries where did all the
workers go basically I was at at Uber I
knew I wanted to start something of my
own but during Co I actually saw how a
lot of things were fundamentally
changing and there was a massive labor
shortage I had kept thinking about this
problem in which case a lot of things
had changed and like the essential
worker was essentially like front center
and everyone was actually putting on
those masks and going to the
distribution centers to make sure that
the world still had food on the table
and to make sure that everyone still had
masks so I I just got super deep on it I
like went online tried all the different
competitor platforms none of them
actually solved the problem um none of
them catered anything to the business
side the idea was simple build an Uber
eat style gig Marketplace that would
connect workers with open shifts at
distribution centers and event venues
old school staffing agencies have been
trying to solve this problem for decades
but the industry is still massively
inefficient so the way a traditional
Staff Agency runs is they have an office
and they have a t sales operation and
when you submit a request for 20 workers
they're actually calling a bunch of
workers to be like would you be willing
to work at McMaster Car um they also
have actual like offices so you have to
run an office a telephone Bank you have
all these people making phone calls
people will literally just sit there
waiting to get called to be like hey we
need 20 people to go sit in this van so
now there's more stuff well the most
important thing that's broken into the
light Industrial Staffing or basically
any temporary staffing industry is
what's known as a fill rate which
basically is about 45 to 50% which
basically means if you request head
workers you get five you can't fill the
shifts it takes too long the quality of
workers are terrible in addition there's
also uh a long lead time so you
basically have to submit a request for
hourly staff at workers traditionally
before trial at least a week in advance
so God forbid you have variable demand
in the last week there's nothing you can
do Staffing is the current solution to a
a very severe problem of the fact that
your labor which is your number one like
like your number one cost is not able to
like Flex up and flex down with your
business and everybody who uses hourly
wage workers just accepts that as
acceptable and this is the first key
strategy Mike is using targeting a niche
market that can expand massively over
time tra started as a light Industrial
Staffing Company serving Miami that
sounds ridiculously Niche but as you'll
see starting small is actually the best
way to attack the massive Global labor
market the Staffing industry is a huge
industry it's 520 billion dollars on a
global basis but it's but it just
doesn't work and so if worker you know
variable labor makes sense the fixed
cost of holding people on staff when you
have variable demand makes no economic
sense the only reason it exists is
because people actually needed to run
their businesses Mike knew there was a
big opportunity here but he had a bunch
of obstacles in his way he'd need
workers to download the app he'd need
companies to agree to hire workers on
tra and he'd also need a technical
co-founder to help him build
it the first step for him was not
raising Capital was to recruit an
appropriate co-founder and he had some
ideas about how to go find one was sort
of pseudo interviewing people so he
joined an accelerator program called on
De in 2020 and met ache buiga yeah so
I'm a the co- Conor and CTO ER at Tron a
Stanford engineer with years of
experience at high growth tech companies
uh and I remember the weekend before the
program I'm sitting on my girlfriend on
my fiance's couch and I was scrolling
through these these bios and reading
them and I I I get to Mike's and I'm
reading it obviously is a very
impressive bio and my uh my girlfriend
is reading over my shoulder she's like
this guy's a winner you should
definitely talk to him um and then that
that uh that weekend like the next day
they had our the first like onboarding
sessions and all those things and so one
of those breakout roomors I was in the
room with Mike as well I do think it's
like a gift from God that I met hche
like I I genuinely and like I had met a
lot of people like he was by far the
most impressive that I had met and so we
started talking he started telling uh
telling me more about the idea for tra
so I knew that I had to like sell him on
the vision I was like this is where
we're going to go this is like why we're
going to win in this Spas we really
headed off immediately really clicked
and I was really excited about what he
was starting to work on with uh with the
idea for tra with oay on board he could
now build the tech but Mike also wanted
to scale tra as quickly as possible so
Mike needed VC funding so we reached out
to my colleague Keith R boy at Founders
fund to meet up and discuss the business
I actually didn't know much about
Venture Capital so despite being in
finance before I found an air table that
had a bunch of investors that were in
the Miami region where I was I was
living and he was one of them I believe
Mike read about it Mike was already
living in Lami and sent me a LinkedIn
message so I said hey Keith I'm like
working at Uber but I'm building
something big would love to chat so I
scanned his profile which had a several
impressive uh ingredients we went to
coffee across the street and he told me
about uh like more about what he do
that's how I initially met him he sort
of actually refused to tell me about tra
uh for months after we became friends
cuz Keith actually the time I had not
really pitched him but but he knew I was
working on it he wanted to be perfect
and you know he wanted to have
everything like perfectly aligned and
then one day we're having coffee and he
has his laptop and he was willing to
show me like the first time like a draft
him a deck uh it was actually really
really really impressive uh so it
immediately clicks with me that it was
both a good idea and that he was very
well suited to do this I ended up
meeting Keith as well that time so Mike
and had met Keith I think a couple
months before that o was working with me
in Miami we went to uh dinner with ke
Mike wanted to make sure that he had the
right co-founder so he he he scheduled a
joint dinner for me to sort of pseudo
interview and uh check the matchmaking
Keith had heard the stories about OE at
the spelling being and uh halfway
through the dinner uh a told me a story
a had competed in one of these like
spelling be kind of things National
Championship kind of thing junior year I
believe he finished third and kind of
like sort of kind of Choke to serve a
thir uh but then instead of giving up he
went back in next year to win as soon as
he told me the story that he went back
to next year to win I was like this is
perfect for Mike moment oxy came on
board we like refined some materials he
worked with the a design agency to just
like clean it up a bit I was in San
Francisco at the time so I flew out to
to Miami and I was like okay I'm going
to work with Mike in person for like the
next week um and so we did a like
basically a hackathon weekend together
we just worked together for a for a
while we went and talked to customers we
built like we were in my apartment like
in in my bedroom actually like I'm not
an engineer so I did I did a no code
product and he did actually coding kind
of solidified like there's there's
something here that's a building like we
need to to to double down here so as
soon as I saw about the industry what
was broken how large it was and then he
had ideas about how to fix it I was
already impressed already you know sort
of willing to invest and so ended up uh
ended up closing an amazing seed round
over the next like week or so with uh
with founder son and general Catalyst uh
leading that round we had participated
in Fr Village and from Lux capital I put
in my two weeks at Uber and like I was
ready to build with money in the bank
and a solid co-founding team in place
the team started building the first
product immediately got to building so
like essentially like the the scene
check hit in like August so two years
ago now and then in that case I
immediately hit up Louise who is our
first operations employee and he worked
with me in Mexico with Uber from his
time at Uber Eats Mike knew that
building a Marketplace business would be
very tricky trick you need to match the
supply side with the demand side
perfectly or one half of your users will
be disappointed demand side is the
customers so business customers uh they
are the demand side workers are
essentially the supply side uh that
we're now matching to the demand based
on you know their criteria Mike's team
needed to find workers that needed jobs
and businesses that needed staff at the
exact time in order to match them up but
instead of getting bogged down with
building the perfect system they just
threw everything they had at the problem
essentially they were doing things that
don't scale we did like just Guerilla
like going into the warehousing district
and going door too went out to all the
warehouses we went like around fences to
introduce ourselves to the managers
trying to get a hold of potential
decision makers of these companies and
usually you do get into conversations or
do start getting information whether
they use temporary workers or not doing
those customer interviews like talking
to workers and we were like there's
definitely something here like we should
start building something and see you
know what we can what we can find out we
put something in front of the customer
and see what they how they react to it
so we like coded a prototype of like
what the app could look like Mike and
oay worked hard to build the first
prototype they recruited the first
workers off the street or through
personal networks we would sit in the
back of Ubers and just ask the Uber
driver like hey would you actually be
willing to work in a warehouse um so we
so we started getting like a bit more
density on the worker side we had about
10 workers that we had met we met some
someone on the side of the street and so
we approached him was like Hey like we
have other opportunities on our platform
if you're looking for work um he was
interested we got him to download the
app on the spot um and ended up having
him work at our uh at our first business
customer in the next week like I went
and picked up the workers in my car and
I was like let's go to the first shift
together and then on the shift like we
all made it we were all there together
as a team making sure everything went
well and then I ven modowe the workers
after like it was very much like old
school like that a true founder would do
anything necessary to solve the problem
even if it means getting their hands
dirty their first Big Break came when
they land landed a small company that
had been on Shark Tank this one business
which is actually one of our it's a very
good business of ours it's called CR
Essence so they build they basically
like create Haitian hair care products
and it's a man and his wife and they
were on Shark Tank and the company
needed to ship out products and some
days were much busier than others so
they often relied on temporary staffing
agencies to fill in gaps oxa and I like
we found their address online we showed
up and the the gate was locked Bally
broke into this place knocked on the
door and like introduced our to the CEO
and like we're like we're raders can you
give us a shot the model worked the app
worked workers were getting paid and
companies were able to deliver products
on time again Mike had succeeded in
scaling his first big client but his
next challenge would be even bigger
scaling his own business and the first
Milestone was making a million dollars
in
Revenue but that raise to the 1 million
was basically pulling out like every
stop f in like every event client that
like needed help tracking them down like
convincing them that we could handle
more and more of their work and then
also on top of that like just
aggressively all hands on deck everyone
like calling companies like everyone
trying their hand at it us like
upselling other clients but it was just
like a blitz of like everyone sitting
there being like all right like if you
can talk to someone on the phone like
you're going to pick up the phone and
try to close deals the team worked hard
coming up with Creative Solutions to
problems as they arose so in the
beginning we had no idea about the
supply to dynamic between the workers
and businesses if anything everyone was
saying there was a labor shortage like
wal Street Journal New York Times a
labor shortage in America the US economy
still has a massive labor shortage
workers are nowhere to be found and some
businesses are having trouble hiring
enough workers to reopen fully
interestingly even though the common
narrative in the news was that people
weren't returning to the labor force
Mike and his team saw something
different on the ground The Narrative
everywhere was that people didn't want
to work but there was a lot of lot of
stimulus up there uh that it wasn't
obvious that the worker acquisition was
going to be uh easy in reality we learn
very quickly that everyone wanted to
work they just wanted to work on their
own terms to give people opportunities
to earn money that's convenient that
notches their Geographic preferences and
their times they just you know flock and
so then it was just a question of can we
acquire businesses cuz the worker demand
was really there it wasn't that
Americans didn't want to work they just
wanted to work on their own terms
ultimately it was what economists call
the labor matching problem and we saw a
similar problem crop up after the 2008
financial crisis the 2008 crisis was
that part of it a lot of pieces to it
obviously but the labor market part was
that we had two sectors of the economy
construction and particularly and then
manufacturing that took a massive hit
and those workers had to figure out what
they should do next and a lot of them
sat on the sidelines they couldn't find
anything that that was attractive to
them it was a huge matching problem you
you're sitting in Las Vegas and you're
not sure whether that you're going to
have a job in a week a month six months
or a year and you kind of Hope it'll be
a week so you wait and you don't
relocate you don't move you don't
retrain you don't imagine realistically
that this entire industry that you spent
your life in is never going to come back
for a long time at least to the level it
was before and so you don't adjust and
that's that's a huge problem if Trava
could help people find new jobs that fit
their schedules their Lifestyles and
their economic needs they'd be able to
have a huge impact on people's Liv lives
and build a great business in the
process and this highlights Mike's
second key strategy when you find a
stagnant industry leverage technology to
deliver a 10x better solution and this
is where the trillion dollar figure
starts to look not that insane for
example right now there are 17 different
staffing companies making over $1
billion a year if they can consolidate
that and then expand internationally
they have a good chance of hitting that
number and they already have an
advantage the labor matching problem is
simply too complex to solve with
tradition Staffing phone Banks but
software can make life better for both
workers and the companies trying to hire
them so with tra you download the app
and you just start working it's a true
meritocratic system where anyone that
actually wants to go make a living for
thems and work hard there is a very low
barrier to entry workers on tra can
build a resume of skills establish
connections to other workers and
essentially prove that they can do a job
effectively part of what is broken in
the current system is there's no way to
actually represent the skills that you
have to employers so whether that's like
lifting heavy machinery or like even
tiny things like showing up on time none
of that is actually recorded anywhere so
there's no incentive to keep doing that
so it Trava being able to record that
actually incentivizes workers to to
start doing this this allows employers
to be more confident about who they're
hiring and make sure they have the right
number of people show up on a given day
through GE location tracking the
supervisor doesn't have to actually go
through this whole process of calling
the staffing agency wondering where the
workers are they also can know okay we
have 10 people here right now but then
five will be here in a little bit it's a
perfect situation for technology to
improve outcomes but building it wasn't
easy we had an interview wind up with a
mayor of Miami towards the beginning of
July so I was like all right we need a
race to get this product out there by
that interview so yeah we have something
ready so that when people are watching
the video locally they're like oh great
I can actually just go and download this
basically we had just received funding
and we had made the commitment that
we're going to build the rest of this
app in the spin of a month that's not
something you hear normally building an
entire app isn't something that usually
can just be thrown together in a month
and so then it was like a scramble of
like okay the next four weeks you need
to build out this app to be completely
ready to go and in the stores and
usually the app in Play Store
submissions even takes like a week
sometimes like all right this things
been done in like 3ish three and a half
weeks about how it would kind of go is
like learning as I go and then like
during the day I'd like be working on
actual parts of whatever app we're
building or the website we're building
and that night I'd be watching different
videos I like tutorals and building like
a clean app in react and like good
practices and so uh I I solved on one of
our earliest engineer Morena where was
like okay we'll jump in we're building
all this stuff um and so we kind of just
like put our heads down and Crush
through it for that bling period of time
and so we had sat down and totally just
destroyed the app and pushed it out and
it was definitely a celebration at
release time but we didn't stop there we
actually did that and immediately
pivoted into now we have our worker app
out now we're going to turn around and
drop the business app in another month
to like a month and a half after months
of hard work and plenty of sleepless
nights improving tra's app they finally
hit their million-dollar Milestone this
set the company up for their series a
which came from Coastal Adventures we
ended up closing an amazing round um
Coast Ventures uh Samir was the the Leed
that there and so we got introduced to
to them through Keith Keith was
obviously at Costa previous to Founders
fund and um I was having an open store
board dinner actually with Samir and he
was complaining about the culture of
society in America where everybody's
entitled people of a certain age and
Below don't work very hard they don't
know what it means to build a company
blah blah blah and as he said this I was
like I've got the founder for you and so
I was like ring me m and they' actually
turned out they both grew up in uh
Northern Virginia it was kind of Love at
First side I think when Mike and Samir
met because Mike is Central Casting the
way people the way people built
companies startups in the 1970s 1980s
Mike has all that in his DNA on steroids
and Samir has watched for like 20 years
a really good VC company building and he
knows what it takes to win and as soon
as he met Mike he realized that like he
needed to invest see from day one Mike
had wanted to build a different kind of
company one where everyone worked
extremely hard toward a common goal
China Works 996 it's like very much part
of their culture as a result of that
they're really like they're surpassing a
ton of different competitors so it's
really hard to compete with the Chinese
company because if you're not working
like you know crazy hours then like the
company next to you is and they're going
to eat your lunch and so a lot of our
culture is like being in the office like
early and staying late and you'll see
that Mike is very much in the office
very early and then also staying very
late the concept of working 72 hours per
week can be controversial in some
circles but it really shouldn't be
joining a fast pay startup is optional
there are plenty of other companies that
don't work as hard but at tra they Pride
themselves on it that's one of the
things about hiring some amazing people
that they set standards they set the new
standard right and so like you hire
someone amazing they're Now setting an
example for everyone else as well and
it's like everyone who High performing
is a little bit competitive they want to
they want to achieve more they want to
learn more they want to be inspired and
so if they want to set the bar
themselves as well the magic of almost
every iconic company behind the scenes
the first 200 500 employees can tell you
the details every company that really
works has a certain kind of work ethic
and no compromises no excuses no
compromises and so they literally built
that very intentionally from the
beginning everything has been designed
around that after the social network
after all these things happened everyone
wants to join a startup because there's
lots of benefits with that but startups
are very very hard if you actually want
to win and we want to win we're playing
to win it most of the generational tech
companies we know today had extremely
intense work cultures at the start this
was exactly how Jeff Bezos thought about
building Amazon one of the people I
really like Thomas Edison here's a model
of his original light bulb he is famous
for saying one 1% inspiration 99%
perspiration it turns out ideas are the
easy part execution is everything it's
not for everyone but for people who want
to build something big and really love
what they do they wouldn't trade it for
anything and it was this intense work
ethic that carried the tra team through
hard times when they started expanding
things were going well in in Miami but
that's a small Market if tro was going
to have a real impact they needed to be
everywhere so the team identified Texas
as the next Market to expand
into Texas had a similar Staffing
problem to Florida and it was only a
short flight from the tra HQ in Miami
the next goal coming out of the series a
was okay we've proven the model here in
Miami we need to now take it out and
scale it in other locations and prove
that we can do this again and again so
when you're launching a new market you
don't have day on workers there is zero
establishment zero name recognition
especially when we launched our first
market like after Miami and so there
were things like starting off Austin you
know we didn't know going into it that
like the labor Supply would be a little
tighter than say DFW place where no
one's even heard of the brand right like
even by Miami standards we were still
small we're going to another state where
they definitely had never heard of us
was kind of going into where these
workers were already looking for jobs
and so obviously you learned some things
when you launched South Florida for the
first time there's a bit of trial and
error then when you go to Texas you hope
you've learned those you know from those
mistakes and you can smooth out some of
those trials and errors and do another
Mark and you hope you have a polished s
Playbook we have the Playbook we're
expanding across the country essentially
we're going to dominate every state that
we can like legally operate the way we
are operating in that's actually what's
happened a Trava they've been able to
add add layer cake layers of success
flawlessly and that's when you know you
have a formula that really works going
from a single Market Miami to a
multi-state business presented a bunch
of new challenges but it allowed them to
prove that the business model would
scale the most difficult year for early
stage companies in at least a decade
Venture Capital Loans all but
evaporating in Silicon Valley and that's
leading to more startup shutting down
even though the business metrics were
looking solid 2022 was an insane year in
Silicon Valley the NASDAQ dropped over
30% and tons of startups went bankrupt
add to that a crowded market and you'd
expect tra to struggle but was able to
stand out from other startups by
doubling down on his core value of hard
work we dream big we're going for a
trillion we're going to make a company
that has a global impact that is massive
and it's going to take a lot of hard
work so like there's four values are
just Olympians work ethic growth mindset
customer Obsession and dream big and
everything we do is like about that when
you build a company where everyone's
aligned that doing something big is hard
work sweating the inputs really does
matter the faster you do things the
faster you grow the faster you grow the
less chance to is somewh else the fast
fall
so the culture here has always been
through pure work ethic Mike has
literally told me that our moat is hard
work and as simple as it sounds this is
his third key strategy Mike is just
committed to outworking the competition
and has built a team that agrees with
him completely his maniacal focus on
showing up and delivering results every
single day is What's led customers to
keep using the Trava platform to hire
people they know his team will get the
job done and it's also kept investors
committed to backing the company so you
know I found fun uh we like to double
down on the best companies in the
portfolio venture capital is a power law
everybody sort of knows that but most
people don't act on it fortunately
Founders fund over the years and over
the funds has been very strong at having
high conviction bats and really
investing more and more money in the
best companies so we were taking off a
new fund Founders fund 8 and we wanted
to lead the fund with a marquee
signature investment and uh the key GPS
at Founders Fund in the Venture side
Peter and Trey we're all you that tro is
the best from series a to the latest
financing we had proven that we can
launch multiple markets like we weren't
just a South Florida Miami company we
actually could expand nationally into a
bunch of different types of markets and
so we're super excited to lead the new
round and really Double Down um in the
company our commitment to the company um
our confidence in the company and then
the way that it came together is just
multiple board meetings of just like
consistent growth and like great unit
economic
great hires like the founders fund team
was in Miami so like Keith and Matias
and a bunch of the the folks who like
actually meet all the colleagues and
they they come by the office at like 10:
p.m. and be like this is crazy like the
energy in this office is like the olden
days at PayPal this isn't a sexy
industry most people don't ever think
about the workers whose job it is to
make Logistics centers run smoothly but
this is a vital part of the American
economy it's such a boring thing from
the outside looking in like you think
like oh the supply train like so
abstract like a lot of people fall
asleep at that like when you truly
understand it then that helps your
ability for like Business Development so
much cuz it's like everything you do is
impacted by it now like this is a place
that puts garlic into like jars so that
they can go to a grocery store so they
get shipments of garlic there's like
garlic like wrapped paper on the floor
everywhere smells like garlic and I'm
thinking to myself like this is this
hidden world that people don't know like
you eat a b bite of a chip little do you
know there was someone on like like a
production line who was like making sure
those chips were right and making sure
they came out of like the oven properly
and aren't burned and there's someone
picking that off everything in this room
right now probably went through a
warehouse and it's like once you start
to realize like this isn't just like
food this isn't just like heavy metals
this is like everything around us has to
go through this world and there's people
who are making this happen every single
day if you are in the supply chain
traditional employment where you get a
schedule you accept a job you go work at
the job you don't know the working
conditions you don't know the culture
whereas like that's why having like an
actual like Marketplace it actually
unlocks a meritocratic system on both
businesses and workers traa breaks so
much of the conventional wisdom about
modern tech companies Tech has been
obsessed with automation but Mike thinks
that the real immediate need is just to
help companies find the human workers
they need more efficiently it's actually
never the case where we walk up to
somebody and say
how's how's it going with your labor
side of your business no one says it's
going amazing it's more of just like can
I trust that you will actually fix it
this time in which case once they try
they love it Trava is a fascinating case
study in how to build a high growth
startup in 2023 and I hope you learn
something from this thanks for watching